e Herkese merhabalar Bugün size
dinleyeceğiz konulardan bahsedeceğim
kadına yönelik şiddet çok çeşitli çok
uygun bir alandır ve çok çeşitli
uzmanlık alanları tarafından ele alınır
Ve bu alanların içinde sosyoloji
psikoloji sucuktan sonra rehberlik çocuk
gelişimi Tıp birçok alan vardır fakat
dil ve cinsiyetçilik ilişkisi nispeten
daha arka planda kalan bir konudur
Halbuki sandığından daha güçlü bir bağ
vardır dil ve cinsiyetçilik arasında
yakanın kadına yönelik şiddet bağlamında
Şimdi sizlerle gibi bir bilmece üzerinde
düşünelim sonrasında konularında detaylı
konuşacağız önceki sinir bilmece
paylaşacağım şimdi anlatacağım şeyle
ilgili lütfen Cevabı bulmayı tahmin
etmeye çalışın bir baba-oğul yolculuk
yapıyorlar ve bu yolculuk esnasında çok
büyük şiddetli bir trafik kazası
geçiriyorlar bu şehre
Bu bir kazansın sonunda baba vefat
ediyor çocuk hayatta kalıyor ve ağır
yaralı bir şekilde bir hastaneye
götürülüyor hastaneye götürüldüğü zaman
ona müdahale etmesi gereken Cerrah
çocuğu gördüğü zaman şöyle bir cümle
kuruyor ben bu çocuğa meyledemem Bu
benim oğlum Şimdi burada bu cerrahım
çocuklu olan akrabalık ilişkisi nedir
size Bunu soruyorum sizce nedir Evet
önce düşündüğünüz babasının vefat
etmişti ama Cerrah Erkek olmalı Eğer
değilse o zaman babası da vefat ettiğine
göre annesi Dirier düşündüğünüz
Muhtemelen Tabii ki istemiyorum ama
büyük oranda çok sayıdaki bir kitle bu
bilmeceyi tekrar tekrar düşünmek
ihtiyacı hisseder Aslında bunlar hiç bir
yanlış bir şey yok Şöyle ki beynimizin
temel öğrenme prensibi maruz kaldığı
uyaranları bir şekilde sınıflandırarak
uygun ve benzerlikler bulduğu
kategorilerle benim izleyerek öğrenme
gerçek
Ya aslında bu yüzden aslında günlük
hayatımız kalıplaşmış rutin leştir
dediğimiz birçok bilginin üzerine inşa
edilmiştir ve bu şekilde etkili ve
pratik bir hayat sürdürürüz bu temelde
Aslında cerrahın erkek olma bilgisi de
bizim hayat boyu deneyimlerinden yola
çıkarak bir şekilde edindiğiniz bilgi ve
ilk başta bunu bilmeceyi duyduğumuz
zaman bunun üzerine bir sorgulama
geçiriyoruz büyük bir çoğunluğumuz
aslında burada Tam da bu noktada yani
dilimizin ve ve cinsiyet arasındaki
ilişkinin daha detaylarına girmek için
bu alanda çalışma yapan bilim
insanlarının görüşlerini sizlerle
paylaşmaya çalışacağım Aslında toplum
dilbilimciler bir ve cinsiyet ilişkisini
üç temel başlık altında toplarlar
Bunlardan birincisi dil kullanımı ya da
daha doğrusu şöyle söyle
Bu arada erkeklerin konuşmalarında
farklılık olup olmadığı Yani aynı dilimi
Konuşurlar ya da Konuşmaları farklıdır
değildi bir konu budur ikinci konuda
kadınların konuşuyor kadınlar ve
erkekler arasında konuşma davranışları
bakımından bir fark olup olmadığıdır Bu
ikisi arasında fark var burada birazdan
değineceğim son olarak da
konuşulanlardan bağımsız olarak dilim
kendisinin yapısal sesli timsel ya da
sözcük üzerinde cinsiyetlere yönelik
ayrımcı gösterip göstermediği konuştur
Bir konuya gelirsek bir konu cinsin
pazarlık konusu farklı üzerinde yer alır
Ve tabii ki Lütfen şunu açıklama
izinleri bu bahsedeceğim çalışma
sonuçları 1900 özellikle 1960'lı
yıllardan günümüze kadar gelen süreçte
yapılmış çalışmalar ve bu son yıllardaki
özellikle dünya genelinde artan
farkındalıkla Bu konuyla ilgili Ben
önümüzdeki var ki çalışmaları farklı
sonuçlara göstereceğim düşün
bu için sizinle paylaşacağım sonuçlar
Aslında birazcık daha bugüne kadar Ne
olduğuyla ilgili devam edelim özellikle
kadınların ve erkeklerin dil
kullanımları incelenmiş ve aralarda
Tabii ki belli farklar bulunmuşlar kadar
şöyle sıralanmış erkekler toplum
tarafından kabul Görmeyen bir yapılarını
daha sık kullanırken kadınlar bu dil
yapılarını daha az kullanmış ve bunun
Sebep olarak da kadının toplum
tarafından kabul görme ihtiyacını daha
fazla olmasından dolayı bir kullanımında
daha kısıtlı olduğu daha az Özgür olduğu
erkeklere göre ortaya koymuştur Ayrıca
bu farklılık yalnızca bir kalıpların
kullanılması bakımından değil sesletim
de gözlemlenmiştir Örneğin kadınların
daha melodik ve hızlı erkekler ise daha
tekniklere yavaş konuştuğunu ortaya
koymuştur çalışmalar Hatta buradan yola
çıkarak diğer et
e-ticaret gibi kavramları ek olarak bu
cinsiyet Temelli kullanım farklarını
göndermek üzere Can Dilek diye bir
kavram türetilmiştir İngilizce'de ikinci
konuda kadın ve erkeklerin dili
kullanırken kullanmışlar gösterip
göstermediğini bu davranışlar Kim daha
çok konuştu Kim daha sık konuşmayı
kestiği kimin konuşmayı başlattı yada
kimin konuşma esnasında daha
destekleyici olduğuyla ilgilidir bu
alanda çeşitli araştırmalar
yürütülmüştür bulgular şöyle kadınların
erkeklerden daha çok oluştuğu ortaya
çıkmış ve dil kullanımında söz kesme
oranlarına bakıldığında da bir asimetri
fark edilmiş Ama bu asimetrinin size
daha fazla detaylarını vermemi izin
verin lütfen Öncelikle dinleyici ve
konuş ucu konuşmayı başlatan cinsiyeti
birbiriyle aynı
bu söz kesin oranları birbirine eşit
bulmuş yani kadın kadınla konuşurken
erkekli konuşurken kesin oranları 45-55
arasında değişmiş Sokak Komşulardan biri
kadın biri erkek olduğu durumda
erkeklerin 196 oranında söz kestiği
gözlenirken kadınların secde 4 oranında
sözünü kestiği gözlemlenmiş Hatta bu
ilişki kadınlar kilo arasında güç
ilişkisinin yere aşık olduğu durumlarda
Örneğin bir şirkette kadının bir erkekle
daha üst pozisyonda 3 ilişkisi olarak
daha fazla hücre sahip olduğu konularda
bile erkeklerin daha fazlasını kestiği
gözlemlenmiş 3. polise pirinçlerin
üzerinde durduğu çocuk olursa dil ve
cinsiyet etkileşiminde dilin
konuşulanlardan bağımsız olarak
cinsiyetçi yapılar gösterip göstermedi
burada İngilizce'den yola çıkarak
örnekler vereceğim özellikle üçüncü
tekil şahıs zamiri o İngilizce'de üç
farklı
bu işi şeklinde gerçekleşir bu şekilde
kullanılır buna benzer şekilde yeni
sözcük düzeyinde yapısal kullanımının
harcını yara Buna ek olarak bazı
sözcüklerin de kullanımı Türk çeşitlilik
gösterir Örneğin yüksek lisans ya da
lisans dereceleri için kullandığımız Ben
çadırı ve Master sözcüklerinin kadın
karşılıklı olan sister ve mystery
sözcükleri kullanarak incelenmiştir
karşılaştırılmıştır karşılaştırmak
olduğu gözlemlenmiştir kadınlar için
kullanılan sözcükler negatif anlamda
anlam genişlemesine olur ki erkekler
için kullanılanlar tam aksi yönde güç
kazanan daha prestijli lerin ya da
kullanım alanı da olumlu şeyleri
çağrıştıran şekilde anlam gelişmesinde
uğramıştır buna benzer bir kullanımda
yani daha doğrusu İngilizce içinde
İngilizce özelinde üçüncü bir kullanımda
lezyon çatının dışında bir çiftle hitap
ederken
da gitti erkeğin isminin yaşlı önceki
erkek hitap edilmesi ve sonrasında
kadına hitap edilmesi durumlara örnek
verir bu kullanılan İngilizce sınırlı
değildir Almanca'da Örneğin isimlerin
cinsiyetleri vardır mesela dert birkaç
seyreder bu törende olduğu gibi kedi
değişirken köpek evi cinsiyet belirtir
aynı şekilde İtalyanca ve İspanyolca da
aynı Güneş sözcükleri için herkesin de
farklı cinsiyetler kullanılmaktadır
Tabii ki bu dillerin dışında Türkçeye
baktığımızda günümüz Türkçe'siyle Avrupa
dil ailesi grubundaki dillerle
kıyaslandığında yapısal dilbilgisel
düzeltici de çok fazla cinsiyetçi
özellik göstermez fakat sözcük düzeyinde
diğer dillerde gözlemlediğimiz bu anlam
genişlemesi ya da Anam olumlu ve olumsuz
anlam genişlemesi diye bahsedelim
Türkçede olduğu görülür be hanım ve bay
bayan aynı şekilde kadın
var ya da mesela Kadın gibi adam gibi
kullanımları da her zaman kadın için
olanın çarşıları biraz daha olumsuz yöne
doğru genişlerken erkek için olanların
ki olumlu yönde kullanılır bütün bu üç
kullanımda Aslında bize daha önce teorik
olarak iddia edilmiş kuramsal olarak
ortaya koymuşsa bir Board hipotezi nedir
Sen belirlemecilik kurallarını
hatırladığı bu kuramlar şunu söyler
dillerde düşünce arasında Çok karmaşık
bir ilişki vardır ve bu karmaşık
ilişkide dil Aslında düşünceyi etkiler
ya da da her şekilde ikisi birbiriyle
yoğun bir şekilde etkileşim içindedir ve
bu yüzden de aslında kullandığınız dilde
yaptığımız değişiklikler düşüncelerimizi
de bir şekilde değiştirebilir buradan
yola çıkarak şimdi günün sonunda bizim
öğrenmemiz gereken Yani ilk örneğimizde
geri dönersek kadın cerrah
bu peki bilmece geri dönersek Aslında ne
yapmamız gerekir Peki biz evinin Bu
konuşmanın başında çok kişi cinsiyetçi
düşünceleri olduğunu düşünüyordu ama bu
bilmeceyi ortaya çıktı ki aslında
bilinçaltımızda yer etmiş uyaranlarla
oluşturduğumuz bazı kalıp bilgiler var
Garanti aldığımız her zaman cebimizde
taşıdığımız bunlarla başlamak için neler
yapabiliriz iki tane yol önerilir
genellikle Bunlardan birincisi
cinsiyetçi kavramları cinsiyetçi olmayan
kavramlarını değiştirmek Örneğin bugün
bilim adamı demek yerine bizim insan
demek işadamı demek yerine iş insanı
sözcükleri tercih etmek bunun için
atılabilecek en önemli adımlardan
biridir bunun gibi örnekleri çoğaltmak
gerekirse Örneğin bir şirket hitap
etmemiz gerekiyorsa önce kadını söyleyip
sonra erkeği söylemek yine bunları bir
örnek olabilir ikinci olaraksa bu
kalıplaşmış cinsiyetçi ön yargılarımızı
mümkün olduğunca çok farkına varıp da
o üzerimize getirip kasıtlı olarak bu ön
yargıları açmak şöyle olabilir şoför
deyince ilk aklımıza gelen Örneğin erkek
Gürse kadın şoförlerle olabileceğini
yazıştığı bir operatörün mesela Kadın
bir operatör olabileceğini kadın
cinsinden birisi olabileceğini de göz
önünde bulundurarak Yani cinsiyetsiz bir
şekilde bazı sözcükleri düşünmeye
kendinizi zorlayarak bunu başarabiliriz
bunu yapmak mümkün konuşmanın başında
dediğim gibi Aslında birçoğumuz eminlik
bu bu cinselliğe yaklaşımı kendimizin
taşımadığını Ama bu küçük de görürsen
Ufak da olsa Dilimize yerleşmiş
kavramlar Aslında bizim ve etrafımızda
bu dili ortak kullandığımız kişileri bu
düşüncelerini daha çok yerleştiren
kalıplaştırma an durumlar O yüzden
bireysel olarak kadına yönelik şiddeti
önlemenin bir yolu da bu kullandığımız
cinsiyetçi dili bu ifadelerden
cinsiyetçi ifadeler
bu arındırmak ve bunları yargılarımızı
yemekten geçiyor kadına yönelik şiddete
dikkat çekilen Bugün de herkesi
kullandığı dilde daha özenli ve dikkatli
olmaya davet ediyorum Son olarak da
hemcinslerinden yerde karşı cinsten
çeşitli nitelikte ve alanda şiddete
maruz kalmıştır kadınları sevgiyle
kucaklıyorum ve dinlediğiniz için
teşekkür ederim